hey uh this is amazing lauren beauberg
radical and repugnant republican
congresswoman lauren beaubert apparently
in her desire to complete compete with
marjorie trader greene
is now going after wanton killing i know
i i'm saying that correctly in the sense
of this is how she said it preaching
from a bible verse lauren beaubert
didn't understand the word wanton
and instead
attacked wonton killing
taking a very forceful stand against
chinese dumplings and then
all hell broke loose
rampant evil grabbing and grasping
vicious backstabbing
they made life hell on earth with their
envy wonton killing i don't know what a
wonton killing is
i'm gonna have to look that one
up it is hard to think of a woman more
dim sum i'm sorry
a woman more dim than lauren beaubert is
what i mean
this is actually the thing trump does
trump does this thing where he reads the
speeches that someone else wrote for him
and he reacts to them like he's reading
a news article trump will say during a
speech
and it is once again democrats who a
dozen times have acted to try to get us
banned from twitter that's true that's
actually true well didn't know that but
that's true he'll re he's doing a
commentary on the speech which makes it
very hard to believe that it's actually
his words it's the exact same thing with
lauren bober
wonton killing there's by the way you
know how i talk about this theme of
these right-wingers who are incredibly
confident about things they're
completely wrong about here's lauren
beaubert explaining to others
the right way to say
inalienable
we the people have been endowed by our
creator with certain inalienable
rights that's inalienable
and alienable um
unalienable um they are unable to be
taken right
unalienable that's a very very important
declaration so there's lauren bobert
these people continuing to be visibly
confused at the things that someone puts
in front of them to write
and
it is quite a doozy quite a doozy